escuadra amaneció con un nuevo
mantenimiento ocurrido en el centro
penitenciario de la provincia de santo
domingo desde la madrugada de este lunes
se producen enfrentamientos entre
integrantes de bandas delictiva por el
control del territorio en los centros
carcelarios se produce a un mes que las
mismas bandas criminales se amotinaron
desde el centro carcelario de turi en la
provincia de azuay en esta ocasión 112
privados de libertad fueron recapturados
al intentar escapar mientras que 108
permanecen fuera del centro carcelario
según informaron las autoridades un
operativo de seguridad ha cercado tres
ciudades del país para buscar así a
estos privados de libertad que
permanecen fuera del centro carcelario
en el cuadro han fallecido al menos 400
privados en libertad en los últimos dos
años en enfrentamiento de organizaciones
delictivas relacionadas al narcotráfico
que se disfrutan principalmente el
control de las cárceles las autoridades
aseguran que las bandas criminales
tienen ramificaciones tanto dentro como
fuera de los centros carcelarios además
el 25 de abril 15 privados de libertad
resultaron heridos en un enfrentamiento
en una cárcel de quito el 3 de abril
también se produjo el primer gran
enfrentamiento entre bandas delictivas
durante el gobierno del presidente
guillermo lasso
que murieron 20 reclusos también los
ocurridos el 23 de febrero de 2021 donde
hubo enfrentamientos de manera
simultánea en tres centros carcelarios
donde murieron 178 reos la comisión
interamericana de derechos humanos a
expresar su preocupación por generar una
política carcelaria y atender más a los
centros del país en 3 ciudades del país
se mantienen en estado de sesión ante
los elevados índices de criminalidad que
no han tenido resultados positivos más
bien han generado 18 personas fallecidas
a paralelamente esto se realiza mientras
el presidente de república ha viajado a
israel para lograr acuerdos
principalmente en materia de seguridad